so dane hypernova
finally got his 3d camera remember the
one is that was you
want to take him to the hardware store i
don't want to see any aspect of dayton's
life
in 3d though you know what i mean
like can we get a 3d camera like you
know the dober brothers at least have
like
you know 19 year old girlfriends in a
swimming pool
like that's something you'd be like put
a vr headset on but why the f
would i want to see dayton hypernova's
life in 3d
well because it feels like you're
sitting in the skin flakes yeah it's
like you're sitting in the filth
it's like you're right there in the
filth i don't want to view
dayton hypernova's life with a special
pair of glasses
i think it's hilarious because i mean i
cuz i never i i try not to plug when we
get these because we
they're unlisted so no one's really seen
these yet i love how much the chat just
marks out every time dayton comes on
so uh he finally got the 3d camera when
a solid mid carder would come out in the
attitude era
he gets he doesn't get a full main event
pop but he gets like a valve venus in 98
pop
uh or diesel it's a pittance
so this is um he finally got but if you
by the way we want to catch up with dane
hypernova uh g luc's been clipping the
whole saga
on the uh clip channel
youtube.comtcmedia so this is uh
well let's just watch it i mean i think
it's because this is gonna be good okay
so this is putting up the last of the
aluminum in my attic to film my debut
3d feature uh dayton it's pronounced
aluminium
i think you're right
here we go
that's not aluminum that's mylar
um it's my large stupid last hour of
your 2020. oh no it really is he's using
aluminum foil
the last hour of 2020 i'm exhausted from
it this is what he was doing new year's
eve
my brother he beats me in this grow
house
trying to get this room ready to film
i'm filming my first
3d project tonight uh
and it's 11 37
show right there i don't know if that's
obvious or not
um that's a cute little story anyway i
guess i'll
show it's 11 37 and i'm about to
nobody cares what time it is of the
aluminum up here
um i'm filming from my other this is
this is one of my ipads
you know he has two ipads all over the
time wasting that he does like
it's 11 30 and i will bet you that his
dad
probably hit that [ __ ] at like nine in
the morning ready to go
the dad probably brought it all upstairs
to the addict
yeah and probably said i need you to
start getting that done today
and now it's 11 30 at night and new
year's eve
new year's eve he's got a
third of the job kind of done but also
done very shitty
and he's still [ __ ] off filming and
talking like
you see you know what i mean like dude
this weekend i had so much [ __ ] to do
like unpacking cleaning my house you
just do it
you eat an adderall and you [ __ ] plow
through it you don't
sit around and go i'm gonna stop and
take a break and i have to do
i'm gonna make a video maybe i'll have
some you know
maybe i'll just sit for a couple minutes
you just go alright what do i need to do
bang out a list bing bang bang bang bong
and then after two hours you're like
ah i'm done this was great you could
have done this job
in two hours start filming a little bit
so
i'm just showing that i'm getting this
ready the year is 20 20 and i'm trying
to have my first production already but
it'll probably be
nice doing a production remember a
couple months ago he needed them he he
needed money because he was buying the
dresses on his mom's credit card
to make his little boutique that you
don't pay for anything remember that as
a little date and boutique
well yeah and this is why it's one of my
big pet peeves honestly
it's maybe it's just because i grew up
because
my old man was kind of like that and and
it's like
who's that a lady in the picture it's my
old lady a small
lady i forgot that line that's great
that's the only idea
that's small lady well it rained for a
couple of days
and then it stopped that's it i almost
remembered something else but it's gone
um no like like i've known people my
whole life that's really
it's it's a pet peeve of mine is that
you know the people that
you'll see them at the bar on a friday
night and they'll be drinking hanging
out doing some
with you and they've always got some new
[ __ ] bright idea that they are manic
about
and then you're like all right yeah but
it's like after a while you're like this
guy every week it's
i'm gonna open up a sports bar and then
the next week i'm starting a party bus
business always says yeah and it's like
you know it's exhausting
dealing with people like this so i get
like just
you just honestly everybody listening to
my words right now
find a thing and get not even great at
it you just have to be
decent at it and if it can feed you do
it
but if you're gonna constantly just
follow your manic depression into these
new schemes every week
you're never gonna get anything done
this this
is this is one of the worst kind of
people to have to support
is the one that's like where you go look
you got to get a job
all right we can't just keep paying you
to do laundry not only do laundry but do
it poorly
um you're ruining the attic you're
taping
aluminum foil to the roof i don't know
what you're planning last week it was a
[ __ ] clothing boutique
these people are draining
[Music]
slightly into your 2021 when it's
finished so i'm going ahead and
i'm doing this and
i'll get on with this i'm going to skip
ahead a little bit
so he's just filmed this is a 12 minute
video of him filming himself putting
aluminum foil off
chaotic noise on your ears so
well i'm sorry i got to hear that gotta
hear that back up here this all this
spells up too for now
here's the full autumn
there's a lot of fireworks in the
neighborhood going on so
and random gunshots that are gonna go so
and the ghetto
is just you know chaos in general he
doesn't live in the ghetto by the way
he doesn't live in the ghetto he's
pretending he lives in the gate he
doesn't live in the ghetto
lots of chaotic noise on your ears
so that's what's going on on that side
it's surprisingly quiet right this
moment i'm sure it's about to get really
loud as it gets close to midnight
yeah it's new year's eve that's usually
what happens dayton
all right
skipping a little bit here
so he's doing he's filming something
with his 3d camera he's setting up the
set
i don't know what it is because he
hasn't mentioned what it is what can he
possibly be filming in a room
is he trying to is he trying to recreate
joe rogan's studio
because why else would you be putting
all this aluminum foil up
uh maybe he's filming a hype williams
video oh
[ __ ] you're right so let's take it yeah
get the suits get the [ __ ] throw your
rollies in the sky wave them side to
side
yeah okay that's fair enough aaron hey
you know what
fair enough he's gonna [ __ ] he's gonna
find a black chick who's really really
talented but unfortunately also very fat
and ugly
and he's gonna blow up a giant garbage
bag and put her in it f in the chat for
missy elliott's career huh my god dude
hype williams was trying to work
miracles with that beast
[Music]
maybe he's filming like a retro kind of
space movie
okay yeah all right i see what you're
saying like some sort of spaceship
sci-fi like something that you would see
on like uh mystery science theater back
in the day got it got it okay
hello this is the robot room or so you
know like just some kind of bad
sci-fi thing all right
maybe he's trying to show you what a
pop-tart feels like yeah
or maybe he's just trying to grow some
weed i mean let's not hate him he
wouldn't grow weed he's not that if are
you kidding me that would involve work
honestly growing weed is so hard i know
it's people
for real it's not easy unless you're
just gonna try to grow like a plant here
and there you could probably
pull that off but man show some respect
to your weed growers
pre-legalization growing mushrooms
growing mushrooms is easier than growing
weed
by a million oh yeah mushrooms you just
stick them in a dark closet and
going to do that thing but weed is dude
it's for
somebody that likes saying growing weed
is [ __ ] easy no when when it's
especially back when it was illegal and
you had to hide it you had to
do it indoors the right way trust me
it's it's
shitty weed yeah that's easy of course
you can grow a plant
maybe you know what it is maybe he's
feeling a maybe he's filming a baked
potato documentary
that's you know it is my life
as a wendy's baked potato
um i don't think wendy sells baked
potatoes anymore
are you sure almost positive i like that
i'm curious because they used to i don't
think they do anymore i think kova
changed a lot of things
okay i'm going to skip ahead again a
little bit more here
you know we always hear this noise when
he's filming in his pocket maybe this
he always has aluminum foil in there
that's what we're hearing
okay i'm skipping to his next video
because i can't take this noise anymore
it's actually
making me feel bad uh this is his uh
this is the behind this got baked
potatoes baby they do
all right hey good for wendy's [ __ ]
eggs uh behind the scenes prepping so
this is the behind the scenes
okay film project i might i i
i'm trying to how this dad hasn't killed
him is beyond me
like i i it's one thing to have somebody
that's constantly like
you know dad i need money and i'm never
leaving
and i'm just gonna be a drain here
forever like that's one thing
i think given the economic shift in the
past 20 30 years anyway a lot of people
are staying home longer
there are extenuating circumstances so
you know i'm not going to judge somebody
simply for staying home but
it's one thing to have somebody like i'm
gonna eat all the food in the house i'm
gonna stay home i'm gonna make you i'm
gonna steal your credit card to order 3d
cameras and health burritos
and all to deal with all that but then
to constantly have them like
buzzing around doing like um i'm working
on my project like
that's the thing that would make me go
now i have to kill you
like we've gone from where i was i was
really annoyed by your presence
but now you're taping [ __ ] aluminum
foil to my walls
this is the point where i go yeah you
know what i'm gonna kill him i have to
kill him now
because if you could just maybe be a be
a parasite
but be it quiet be one quietly like be
one of those parasites that sits in your
room all day and just plays video games
or plays on the computer
and i don't have to see or hear from you
but it's like now i'm coming home from
work and you're like
shh
you're going what are you doing and
you're like i'm filming my my filming i
know i had a boutique that i was gonna
do but
now i'm a filmmaker and you're like i'm
going to
kill this person what if he saw
goodman's brother
did you think about that hi zodiac he is
he's chuck
she's chuck from better calls
electromagnetic sensitivity
okay i didn't know that that would be
another made-up disease this [ __ ] has
too
you're right december 31st 2020.
i tried to record i hit record and it
was recording and it stopped and
it's just because my brother he he
abuses he beats the law in this house he
beats the apps
on my ipad he he beats the justice
system
in this house and he's not a good lawyer
he's a bad
my i know my brother jimmy more than
anybody he's bad
sherman just becomes a lawyer it's
amazing some hack school so he could
just ruin his life
so this is kind of an old ipad so i'm
not surprised like kind of
i i think i bought it when it was like
five years old or something when i like
it was already
around i think this is only a second or
third generation i think it's a third
generation ipad
people care in good shape as the other
ipad
that i have that i bought before by the
way it is an old ipad you could tell
because it's filming in four by three
it looks like i'm watching another
episode of the next generation you know
i think it was like a first job you know
earl i've been sitting before
like i've been hanging out with a group
of friends earl please don't detonate
i'm sorry earl
i i have been sitting before like at a
table having drinks with a group of
friends
and i've told stories of like literally
watching somebody get shot and killed
right in front of me
and there's times where you have
everybody's looking at you and they're
really into the story
and and earl there have been times in in
telling a story like that where even i
have doubts and i think to myself
are they interested am i hitting all the
[ __ ] notes
are these people really interested in
the story i have to tell them right
now you're babbling about your third
generation ipad and you don't have
like i what i'm saying is i'm jealous of
his
complete lack of doubt in himself like
he knows what he's talking about people
just need to hear it whereas i've had
legitimate
like stories that were so good that
the story itself wasn't in question i
was like this is a great story but am i
telling it right it happens
am i when you're doing a show correctly
no but yeah when you show up with day
wave nightweave rotc
sometimes you're going is this good for
the audience is this worth it
like you're thinking oh am i
entertaining the people that are
listening he
he is no there's no doubt there's no
doubt
it's unbelievable i i wish i had this
level of confidence this level of
unearned confidence absolutely no doubt
he's telling a story about a second
generation ipad
like he's telling you about the wreck of
the thing fitzgerald
second or third third or second i can't
remember because i remember when we got
it it was either in 2005
but it was in 2006 and there was a there
was a firmware update
in between i couldn't remember if we
returned it if they gave us a new one or
if they fixed the old one
or a third generation with the same
confidence of the dudes they interviewed
for band of brothers
like you know right it's this i mean
dude just the thing is with date we
always pick up new stuff that is a
really that's a really good catch system
he is
just [ __ ] plow right through it he
believes
that this this needs to be a third
minute video needs to be heard
oh my god people ask me sometimes
did i did i have um i had a second
generation ipad was i a hero and i said
no
but i surfed with
if you don't cry when you watch band of
brothers you have no soul but his
called band of my brother beats me in
this house
no the story is told from the dad's
perspective it's band of brothers i want
the [ __ ] out of this house
look we'll maybe finish it's a 15 minute
video maybe we'll watch
more at some point i'm not going to go
through this whole 50-minute video